for Deontay Wilder his best shot in MMA
to win a fight is against Francis for
Francis his best shot to win a box of
matches with Deontay Wilder it makes all
the sense yeah I'm in take my money
what sells more pay-per-views
yeah Deontay Wilder Francis MMA fight or
Jon Jones Tyson Fury boxing fight
what is popping fam Monday morning June
12th it is cloudy again surprisingly
it's cloudy here in calabas California
how is everybody doing how was your
weekend
great grand wonderful can't hear you
guys wish I could although that'd be
straight Mayhem if I could just hear you
guys whoever's watching this it's just
non-stop chatter
like it's Bruce Almighty I just hear you
guys oh well let's be sick a little
dialogue that'd be dope
uh yeah coming fresh off the weekend you
had some fights going on we had a
Calabasas fight companion with the great
Eric Griffin the Schmo it's the Schmo
with dub Pros you had all those guys
going down and Paulie's sure the Paulie
Shore coming in town you have to click
on a chin all right just that distracts
me
um yeah all those guys are in town uh
and on the show it was a good crew man
the the Shimon knows his stuff one of my
faves uh did he drive in from Vegas he
said
I think three of us were up since 5 a.m
that day my day started at 4am today but
on Saturday I think the Schmo City left
at 5am to drive here he had something
going on something like that and then
Paulie Shore was up at five because I
think he was shooting all day Pauly
Shore Instinct character absolutely
loved the dude I think he felt pressure
because
um he doesn't know about fighting he
thought he was gonna be just a fight
show but clearly he's never seen a fight
companion before even when I did the
ones with Rogan uh obviously there's
some fight talk but there's also
sometimes we talked about octopus for
three hours you know it's just you never
know where that show's gonna go so I
felt like Paulie uh felt a little out of
place and he wasn't
he wasn't you know he asked for uh the
first guy for his writer he asked for a
ton of Taco Bell and dude he made a mess
he he put lettuce cheese uh in the
hallway in the bathroom there's like
gordita crunchy I'm like are you 12
Paulie oh my gosh just just like the it
looks like the Cookie Monster the Taco
Bell Cookie Monster came in the studio
then when his dog he runs dog he's not a
pizza there's only one Paul he's
chilling man you gotta love Paulie you
gotta love Polly
um let's talk about the fights it was a
it was a interesting fight companion
interesting night of fights uh you know
I
not the sleeper I thought well ah how do
I want to phrase this not the sleeper we
thought right it was better than you
thought
wish I could hear you guys uh not the
sleeper that we totally thought like
obviously the card wasn't stacked like
we're used to especially in the summer
time this is just an appetizer before
they get into the big cards in July
that's all they're doing here
um thank God Charles Oliveira and banil
Darius was the co-main event which was
the main event uh could use that for
that should have been a five round fight
even though it only went one round that
still would prefer that be a five round
fight uh that's neither here nor there
because it got finished in the first
round all I'm saying is thank God
Charles Oliveira and Darius got switched
because remember this was the fight
months earlier but Charles Oliver
injured his we don't really know what
was going on there but they moved that
to this card and for the Vancouver fans
they are thinking they're fight Gods
right now because if that fight was not
on this card it's tough card man
tough card
um the Canadians I think went 6-0 all
Canadians won every Canadian one on the
card that has to be a first
has to be a first
um because in Dublin when they do them
there in England there's definitely some
Americans that went there and some
Russians uh UFC 134 that I was on I know
this American that got knocked out by
big nog and then
um
who else interesting or yeah Anderson
won on that night
it might have been another night where
all Brazilians won with like the the
country one
someone lost on the main card who's
Brazilian I remember that
let me see if my memory serves me right
somebody lost their
uh not a small guy because I
um
if you go to UFC 134 chin
uh
uh Fight Card results
oh there you go silvo comment okay
uh so hold on uh Anderson Silva Okami
answer one Shogun Force Griffin uh
Shogun one etson Barboza Ross Pearson
Split Decision uh big dog
uh oh there it is Louise Kane lost all
right first round to uh netcoff other
than that all of the Brazilians won
Paula Harry's defeated Dan Miller Thiago
Tavares beat Spencer Fisher got that
card was stack Daddy back in the days
that card was stack bro dude look at
that main card no Louise Cain who at the
time was a Savage we you almost forgot
he was a Savage he lost that night then
he got big nog me fun fight be real fun
fight was on the poster fun fight uh
it's in Barboza Ross Pearson that's
vintage that's in Barbosa son of a [__]
also vintage Ross Pearson England's
England's finest you have Shogun also
pretty Prime Shogun there against Force
Griffin and then Ash and Silva uh one of
the goats one of the best ever do it
against Okami and yeah the Brazilians
had a good night
point is the Canadians had good night I
think they went 6-0 so I thought this
would be the only other card just
obviously unbiased because I was on the
crowd Superman it was a tough night for
non-brazilians right but um yeah that
Russian one okay doesn't really count
he's Russian
um Amanda yeah yeah yep the sweet Adam
fugit definitely the MVP for the
Canadians that boy cheeked up too
handsome bastard handsome bastard all
the way around that boy misses no squats
right right Phuket yeah uh no Adam
foogie got beat up Oh you mean Mike
Mike's the dude who's peached up he's
drinking all the maple syrup goes right
to the cheeks
uh
yeah good looking kid probably the
biggest pop of the night when they
showed him
um
yeah he had a good night man he had a
really good night
he was talking about I saw one of his
pre-fight interviews he like this was
such a big deal for him he put the
pressure on himself he talked about this
going into the fight because he was at
uh when the Toronto when GSB fought Jake
Shields which at the time I think the
biggest life gate I was also there
um because I think that's all same time
Randy Torah fought Leona Machida and I
helped Randy Couture and he got his
tooth knocked out never forget that but
that was the biggest gate at the time
and Mike Malott was there I think he was
like 12. oh [__] and it like inspired
him he's like I want to be the guy that
carries the Canadian flag out I want to
be that guy now
he's on his way to be that guy but I
think this big pop where they put him
you know was definitely a step in the
right direction a talented kid all
finishes he he's I think he's 30
something though so he's not like this
young Prospect
so he's an interesting one but he's
going to get some uh
31. yeah 31.
yeah so he's not like that young but
he's still you know he's newer while
we're talking about Mike Malott um did
you see this part of the the walkout I
don't I don't know if we saw it or not
on the broadcast I saw it on uh people
sent to me I saw it on Twitter the the
so when he walked out it just fell over
so I'll play real quick
and just look at Mike mallott's reaction
he has zero reaction yeah because he's
going to fight another grown man it
falls right on top of him he just moves
and here's a better angle you can tell
they're okay though it's not like it's
not like we see in like
you know in Brazil when the stadium
collapses and there's Millions I mean
they're low so that's good if it was on
top and then oh my God would be a
disaster like if someone fell off the
top rafter or something like that that'd
be a disaster that one I fit when I saw
him together okay and it came out dating
in the press conference like everyone's
okay they might locate them
to better seats yeah
I mean man what's going on there how is
that how's that how has that not
happened before I know just don't get me
wrong I love Mike Malott but there's
been like GSP Ronda Rousey Brock Lesnar
you know Rampage back then how did Randy
toward fights where people are just
Conor McGregor or they're foaming at the
dick to touch the guy how has that not
happen before
that's a new Vancouver
that's on you that's on you whoever put
the nuts and bolts in for the same
judges that screwed me their loving
fight right that's a new Vancouver you
gotta clean it up you got to clean it up
I love Vancouver though have you been to
vancouverton I've been to Toronto with
you but I've been I don't think we've
been to we went to Toronto together yeah
for one of your shows on that huge tour
that we did oh a while ago yeah a long
time ago [__] I didn't know that guy
from um
that Amazon
show
he went with us
it's like a spaceship show that uh Steve
Bezos or not Steve uh Basil's actually
bought the show to renew it
you know what I'm talking about who the
hell you're sure I was there she okay so
the girl that's a commentator or some
for Bellator her husband maybe you don't
leave me no no for Bellator
Jennifer or something like that
oh Jen Brown her husband yeah Wes yeah
that's Chatham oh that's my boy yeah he
was with us he was yeah I don't remember
any of that yeah the details man my
brain Can Only Hold so much and then he
goes delete delete the expanse I think
is called history experience yeah like
big time fan base yeah yeah they wanted
to cancel it they had freaking airplanes
flying over the studios and Jeff Bezos
did it so are they doing it again I
think they're done I'm not sure yeah
that's like one of my favorite people on
the planet yeah I do not remember him
being there he was at the show he was
with us but yeah in the green room we
were we went to where the hotel we went
to a bar we ate food holy [__] yeah dude
you're sure I was there I'm 100 that's
the reason why we were there for you
yeah yeah I love Wes one of my favorite
people on this so anyways I've been to
Toronto and I'm not sure if I've been to
Vancouver unless we went there
completely different okay I mean you
gotta remember how big Canada is that's
like saying yes yeah I've been to New
York same as LA right like they're
completely west coast East Coast
completely different Vancouver is great
man so expensive though I can imagine
ooh daddy the the real estate up there
is I mean it has to be top ten in the in
the world I mean it's so expensive I
just remember Toronto being so clean and
so many pretty freaking girls like yes
insanely but I think best in the world
Toronto best in the world as far if
you're a single man move to Toronto by
far okay well best in the world that's
all what I'm gonna say yeah Vancouver's
right up there though too
Vancouver's fantastic man Vancouver's
dope I haven't toured and I did Calgary
a few months ago
um I haven't done Vancouver or Toronto
in a hot second I gotta get up there yep
Vancouver's fantastic oh I want to go
let's do it yeah yeah I'll plan it chin
oh yeah yeah I'll plan it we'll bring
the crew up there by crew I mean you me
and Jay yeah yeah things are different
though
um let's take a little break from all
the fisticuffs talk on UFC 289 gentlemen
are you ready to take your skin care to
the next level with Father's Day coming
up right around the corner it's this
Sunday it's time to seize the
opportunity and our trusted Partners at
Caldera lab the leaders in men's skin
care have the tools to improve your skin
and your dads man you don't want your
dad looking all weathered like Clint
Eastwood out there you got to get some
moisturizer you gotta get this the cream
under the eyes which I use so I don't
have these nuts hanging off my eyes all
right signs of aging it's not good and
that's where Caldera lab can help you
out so your pops has confidence this
summer join Caldera lab for the skin
care upgrade trust by the countless Bros
out there use code Shabbat Caldera
lab.com that's
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-l-a-b.com to enjoy
exclusive 20 off their finest products
Caldera labs create high performance
men's skin care products by combining
pharmaceutical grade science along with
Nature's Pierce and most potent
ingredients all right they have the
Clean Slate they got the base layer the
good is your go-to at night before bed
it's clinically proven I use it before I
go to bed and if you want to take your
skin to the next level look no further
than the icon that's what I'm talking
about rejuvenating the Eye Serum is here
to address the three most common skin
concerns around the eye Fine Lines dark
circles and puffiness boom look at your
boy I've been up since 4am I know it's
not great I have a puffer fish face but
still better than Jon Jones all right
get Joints off with the coach shop schab
at calderilab.com that's 20 off at
calderalab.com by using Code shop schab
make Father Time a thing of the past
this summer with the best skin care
tools from Caldera lab tell you what
your boy's been up since the crack of
dawn and when I get tired I rely on one
product one product only it's my friends
at happy hippo I use the freaking
instant shot I'm talking about that I
got it right here you can tell this
one's open I use it right before I went
on air I'm talking about that Kratom
shot this is the sour apple I take that
your boy's ready to go I'm zoned in give
you that warm balance zoning good mood
feeling and if you want to try Kratom
you gotta trust the Kratom you can trust
my friends at happy hippo all right my
favorite are the shots whatever you want
to get your Kratom gummies powders they
got it all they even have the K dips
we're talking about Kratom and K dips
it's like the pouches your boy always
uses but we're talking about Kratom no
one's ever it's first to Market this
Wintergreen they have the Razzle Dazzle
blueberry flavor the wintergreen's
pretty nice though but the first ever to
do it so try it out if you want to get
some pouches there the Kratom pouches
first ever to do it Happy Hippos
changing the game they have the best
Kratom on the planet all right so if you
want powders gummies the dips the shots
which I use go to happyhippo.com promo
code is thick 23 you get 20 off for life
that's thick with three C's the number
23 you get 20 soft for Life happy hippo
the best grade one on the planet come
back to the fight though
Mike Malott your MVP of the night I mean
MVP meaning it's his you know home yeah
homecoming home field advantage she
pulled it off the crowd went absolutely
nut for that fight
um
then I mean your overall MVP obviously
if Amanda Nunes didn't retire we're
barely talking about this fight
um it's not a case of Amanda Nunes not
put on a good performance it's a case of
Irene aldana literally doing nothing she
froze in the moment the moment was too
big that's what's going on there if you
look back at the history of aldana's
fights whenever it became the biggest
moment like the the game-changing fight
she never she hasn't showed up and
Invicta the UFC whenever it was like
that next step she never showed up so
yeah if you look uh Holly Holm huge
fight for didn't fight great
um she lost the Raquel Pennington but
then if you look at um her Invicta
fights too
uh if you go to that Tanya evinger huge
fight that was for the vacant of
bantamweight Championship you know she
got beat up so she's never gotten over
that hump there seems to be a mental
block there I thought with the Run
within seven out of nine maybe this
wouldn't be a case I'd even allude to it
on the breakdown on Monday when I did
the breakdown for
um what company do we work with from Ola
TV I didn't I didn't allude to it
because I was like yeah it's got an old
narrative spread it over that hump
that's like saying Charles Oliveira you
know has quit in him clearly freaking
doesn't so it to me it was like I'm not
even gonna touch on that clearly I
should have because that is what hap I
think what happened it's a mental thing
she has the skill set to perform a lot
better than she did she could have went
out on her shield now would she have
beat uh Amanda Nunes that night and no
absolutely not if Amanda shows up and
she's just fighting at 80 percent and
all Donna's at 100 Nunez beats or 10
times out of 10. she's have to show up
at 100 and Amanda doesn't want to be
there in order to beat her the problem
is Amanda Nunes came in we didn't know
this going into it this is their last
fight she showed out she beat the brakes
off of her you know it's just not very
competitive fight she didn't risk
anything she just did that weird high
guard shelled up
um her legs got destroyed her your
midsection got destroyed a man noon has
you know knew it was her last one
um again we're not talking about this
fight unless Amanda Nunez retired which
she did
so
um a lot of people won't remember this
fight so Amanda Nunez retired hats off
to her man I mean by far there's no
argument the grace of all time you look
at who she's beat any girl that ever
touched a championship belt she beat up
you know her resume is insane I don't
think we'll ever see it again the knock
on hers that the one Juliana Pena fight
um if you want to go before that you
know with the cat zagano doesn't matter
because after she lost cat zingano she
beat everybody possible anybody who
touched a belt she beat the [__] out of
him not even close that's a similar
thing to her in GSP the fights aren't
close that's why GSP is considered one
of the goats there's that argument right
the fights were not close khabib the
fights are not close that's how you
separate yourself from the pack when
we're talking about Championship
um Fighters here so she just outclassed
everybody had the Jewel on Pena hiccup
where she didn't show up July showed up
beat her right then all right cool you
beat me beat the piss out of her few
10-8 round I think they definitely gave
her one 10-8 and then with aldana
retired I think part of the reason she
retired there's nothing really left for
the trilogy fight with Pena makes no
sense especially after the last outing
um there's not a lot of other things
going on there the only one I think I
kept around is if chefchenko would have
been Champion they've been the one fight
she probably wants right A lot of people
think chefchenko beat her but even
though chefchenko's in a different
weight class when they did fight that
was a close fight a lot of experts did
give it to chefchenko but then
chefchenko loses to uh Grosso so that's
out the window so there's not a lot left
for Manning this dude she's kind of
waiting around so I think it was the
perfect retirement and I don't think
it's I think she's retiring like khabib
did where there's no chance she comes
back not a chance have to take like a
Ronda Rousey maybe like something super
special get her out of bed but she
sounds like she's done done
by far the best to ever do it no
argument there as far as women goes no
argument
um then Charles Oliveira really stole
the show
boy you almost forgot include myself so
many experts so many people in our field
were picking against Charles Olivera and
it's so weird this guy never gets the
credit that he deserves because
if you look at his resume his strength
of schedule of Fighters that he beat his
his Reign at the the lightweight
division when he was championed the the
names that he beat compared to khabib
it's not even remotely close
it's not even strength of schedule
khabib's Florida Atlantic
you know like it's not even remotely
close Charles Rivera's Alabama
so
keep that same energy when you go to
college football when you look at
Alabama who if they go on the field or
say a Georgia and the SEC goes on the
feed they look at a team who's even in
the Pac-12 or the ACC they go undefeated
nobody goes that's the best team they
blew everybody out well yeah who are
they playing
with khabib it's like he's the best 155
hour time who's he fighting
look at his resume look how long he held
the title for
I I really don't get to argue that he's
the best the greatest ever do it
now he did beat the piss out of
everybody they fought looking straight
up the schedule
his best win is Dustin Poirier
great win don't get me wrong disemporee
great win
he'll be gaichi
would be Conor McGregor Allah Quinta
Edson Barboza
so he won his uh belt off Ally Quinta
then he defended against Conor McGregor
defended against Dustin Porey defend
against Justin gaichi
so when he was Champion he fought Connor
Dustin and gaichi had three hard fights
good Charles Olivera
yeah I guess just his record right
that's why like how long how many fights
he had beforehand that's what makes it
look way bigger it just hit the eyes
that he beat like if you're looking at
Hall of Fame credentials then let's say
there was a greatest of all time and you
go okay well we just went over khabib's
he had his three wins when he became a
champion three really good wins no doubt
cool
Charles Oliveira beat Darius nine fight
win streak now you guys go he's not that
good okay whatever so he beat Darius
he'd be Justin gaichi Beat Dustin Porey
so those two wins that khabib has he
beat Michael Chandler Tony Ferguson that
was a Tony when pretty damn good Tony
right maybe Kevin Lee
um David you know Jared Gordon you know
we can't count that as one of the great
wins but still not bad Jim Miller clay
Guida
will Brooks
you know uh miles jury at the time like
you remember at the time will Brooks was
a big deal right he was a Bellator
Champion came over he beat him miles
Jerry was the next big thing you beat
him
um Jeremy Stevens was very tough in 2000
and what is that 14. very tough
foreign
you just look at his wins dude you know
and then I guess the knock on him would
be the losses you know early in his
career one two three four
and then we all thought he had like him
we thought he had quit hit him and then
he somehow conquered that and got over
it so he's incredible now yeah so take
out the the
pre-champion Run
and go just Champion for Champion run
this isn't even a debate dude
so he won the belt at where at
so he won the belt against Michael
Chandler 21. then one two
so one two three
they lost it to the best so it's similar
it could be right
could we had three two and hmm But yeah
khabib to get the belt fought Ally
Quinta
I mean it's a good argument yeah
I just always value longevity you know I
get there he's still in the game oh yeah
and now for sure there's no other fight
to make it's Charles Oliver and khabib I
wish I [__] wish yeah it's Charles
Oliver
knock job's the closest thing we have to
khabib
so you get the rematch he's a big dog
too I think he's plus 400 plus 300
already and Dana who says he's gonna
make fights after the fights he made the
fight he's like that's let's let's not
make this complicated that's the fight
to make
Plus 250. I don't know if that's the
older one or the new one though yeah I
know
um
now these are old
I typed in odds I saw it on Twitter
there's new odds yeah so I'm guessing
he's gonna yeah his favorite yep still
is
I just yeah my chips just that style
that's gonna be tough for Trump holder
to beat that's a good uh Muk Chev is and
people forget machev out struck him that
fight too
watch as a mother mother trucker did you
ever rematch anyone
no I wish I wonder like if you rematched
if you learned a lot of stuff about that
person yeah I don't know yeah I don't
know what major Charles just had a bad
night you know you get a home he didn't
fight the same way without Reckless
like abandonment and they try and get
them out of there and it looks like I
tapped right away I don't know about
very cautious they want to be in there
could be that shows you a good mock
shove is too he's like holy [__] I can't
get anything on this guy
so yeah
good night fights overall go check out
the Cal bass fight campaign UFC 289
right now on YouTube You Know full
episodes there Clips are there so
appreciate you guys tuning in let's take
a little break this episode of the shop
show is brought to you by the one the
only on it on it man on it they make
alpha brains the number one nootropic on
the freaking planet you've heard about
it you've seen in Whole Foods you've
seen at Walmart you've seen it all over
you're like yeah should I try it how
about this no can you try it there's no
risk there's no risk they give you your
money back you can keep the product
share with a friend who's gonna
appreciate it because it actually works
it's the number one nootropic for a
reason they've sold over a million
bottles now there's the regular Alpha
brings here at Whole Foods and Walmart
and all that then there's the Black
Label what your boy uses it'll get you
basically like Jeff Bezos level of brain
power that's right it's a mental
processing caffeine freeing help helps
promote With the Flow State promotes
Focus supports memory remember names
addresses phone numbers one last time
remember your buddy's phone number think
more clearly under stress on it has it
all have the best nootropic on the
planet in the Alpha Brain they have
instant Alpha Brain they have the Alpha
Brain shot they have the Alpha Brain
Black they have the regular brain you
see at Whole Foods and uh Walmart all
right they offer all that the best
neutral work on the planet but you can
also get 10 off all their fitness
equipment kettlebells steel Club maces
yoga mats protein powders Warrior bars
creatine fish oil uh total gut health
they have it all it's the best
supplements on the planet the best
nootropic on the planet get with the
hype this is real here go to audit.com
shop that's
schabonit.com you get temp shop
everything I just mentioned all Alpha
Brain across the board all workout gear
all workout devices streaming Fitness on
it.com shop let's get back to the
program
um other than that man you had uh Floyd
Mayweather fighting uh John Gotti's
nephew yep or yeah I think we feel like
it's fake
stop the fight because Gotti kept
holding and they kept talking trash to
each other the ref stops the fight then
John Gotti tries to continue the fight
talking [__] to Floyd and then both
Corners jump in there and all the Floyd
people jump in there it spills out even
into the back of the Arena when they
leave the cage
um or in the back too yeah and then John
Gotti's aunt or cousin left a pretty
racist
really Instagram yeah called uh called
Floyd Mayweather's like daughter uh yeah
it was not good if you look it up it's
pretty tough
yeah well
yes I don't get my flights doing this
stuff man I mean he's making some Bank
I'm sure I don't want Floyd's doing this
stuff for even before he asked me like
what am I doing
I mean this happened like in MMA and
boxing like how many security guards are
around the the ring not that you can't
control that many people but even when
Floyd fought uh Logan it wasn't like
this but I'm assuming yeah I don't know
see this person says staged as AF I mean
I can totally imagine it being staged
for sure yeah the whole thing's weird
also don't do that don't fight him Floyd
what are you doing
he has enough money now
what do you got Jen it has to be an ego
thing for Floyd he just want to stay
relevant I kind of feel like Conor is
the same way too like he wants to be in
the public eye so that's why he still
fights yeah they're all set I I think
yeah I don't know or that that hunger
for the fame the the competition you
know because it makes no sense Connor's
coming back exactly he's so rich makes
no sense Floyd's doing this
um so there was a pfl over the weekend
as well and the reason I bring this up
is hello Brendan what's up the Brendan
kid got knocked out yeah big I think
it's a huge favor too right massive yeah
uh but Marlon rise he finally retired
so you know who else retired big yes oh
dude yeah 11 in a row this one at least
you didn't get starched but you just
fought you know some kind of sloppy dude
into decision
it was bad man rice was a bad mama when
he was in his prime he was so fast and
so freaking yeah
Bigfoot Silva suffers 11th Street loss
and finally retires thank goodness I
heard one of the reasons because
everyone's like why does he keep doing
it I heard one of the reasons he's doing
is because
his condition didn't have long lips he's
trying to get as much money as he can to
his family first families damn it
ah thank God man done though yeah thank
goodness
so he can still stay with his family for
as long as he's here and not be
completely gone
um this I thought was very interesting
someone took a picture of
uh Daniel darish after the weigh-ins so
his red they're saying his wedding ring
didn't even fit his finger that's how
much he lost so much
super loose yeah yeah it looks terrible
it seems like he had a really bad weight
cut so I wonder if that was part of the
the whole thing it was just you know the
whole thing he's one of those guys that
you you want him to get the title shot
absolutely so many guys before so many
guys before so he's another one
um it's just a bummer and then with
Amanda Nunes retiring
so we know the 145 pound division is
completely gone that's that goes with
Amanda and then the bantamweight
division it's just like there's this
huge void there now you know
um it's just a huge void at 125 still
stacked you know 25 stacked that's
thriving but 35 it's just you know
35 you have uh
um wait that's pound for pound that's
pound for small weight flyweight so 125
yeah go down it'll be the next one there
it is bantamweight so we have Pena who's
gonna be number one now there'll be no
Champions if Pena Raquel Pennington's
probably gonna fight Holly Holm has a
tough fight if she were to win that's a
name they put up there
outside that you know it's not great
looking and there's like no really like
super young talent that you're vying for
either
is completely wide open man yeah
and a man noon has beat pretty much
everybody there so it's like she said
you know whoever wins just it's a fake
belt and you guys know it because I
retired she's kind of right like and
she's beat all of them I don't know why
I even kind of agreed to that too which
is tough you need some some new Young
Life in that division like uh
featherweight's just done I mean look
they don't have ratings like there you
go
there's no rankings whatsoever it's just
sir
think about it like even outside the UFC
go go to if I'm the UFC I create a atom
weight Adam weight stacked
the UC don't have the division but like
one Championship uh Rising other you
know all around Invicta Adam weight
stacked just think about just like it
with the men there's so many smaller
women walking the plant than a little
bit then there are big so it's gonna be
stacked
I don't wait stack stacked UFC created
Adam weight division 105 to 115.
yeah super light
yeah
they're super skilled though yeah dude
that's what I do if I was DLC I'd shut
down the featherweight and create Adam
weight
to bring Angela over
Angel Lee if she she retired what's up
rumors she's retiring she doesn't want
to fight since her sister passed she's
done finally
oh my gosh I don't break your news for
10.
that story is still strong yeah yeah
that makes you so sad yeah what else you
gotta do
all right let's see
here we go again on my own oh so Deontay
Wilder has mentioned this before how he
would want to fight uh Francis and Gano
but he's doubling down saying that he
would do a boxing match and an MMA match
whatever match would be well it's well
because it's like
Both Worlds I'd be super down to watch
this oh I'm in take my money yeah that's
the best case scenario and if this is
Francis I should say not friends if pfl
can pull this off then it's a win for
Francis this is the only way I will
co-sign friends move to go the pfl is if
he gets a Deontay Wilder a fury a Joshua
fight it looks like Wilder's the only
one willing to play ball here
so if that's the case how in the
Frick do you not show up and square off
against Deontay Wilder when you know
he's at pfl you tell me you didn't know
of course bfl was like Hey done
throughout or just reserved his seats I
mean cage side we're gonna interview him
how do you not how do you miss that
opportunity and not show up to square
off with the underwater and get that in
the news cycle dude that would have been
massive massive complete failure on his
team's part you gotta I don't know where
he's at is he in Africa if that's the
case then I get it but it's not yeah
dude how are you not there
yeah huge opportunity and even with MMA
I mean France out grappled Cyril gone
which isn't saying much sure gone and
Deontay Wilder probably have the same
Jiu Jitsu but
I would assume that MMA again it's the
best shot for both of them
for Deonte Wilder his best shot in MMA
to win a fight is against Francis for
Francis his best shot to win a box of
matches with Deontay Wilder it makes all
the sense yeah I'm in take my money to
the biggest punchers right boxing games
yeah nobody's a hard puncher to the
right now even close I mean last I don't
know how long price since George Foreman
take my money yeah somebody you're
knocked out hopefully it happens oh I
hope it happens for France's sake
um this is cool news so Chris weidman's
finally returning I don't know how long
it's been since he broke his leg but uh
he's returning against uh Brad Tavares I
like this yeah tough fight for both guys
kind of you know great his last fight uh
for Chris Weidman he said he's gonna
open up with the hardest leg kick of his
life which is crazy apparently he's
kicking like I love that
pretty cool
yeah he said because it's it's that
mental block right obviously if you just
get that out of the way that's huge for
himself he's fighting in Boston hell
yeah take my money
and then
this is uh so Jon Jones was at that uh I
think he was at the pfl or Anthony
Pettis's I forget what which place is
that is okay so then uh yeah he was
looking thick in the face super thick
dude thicker than my face let's be
honest yes his face yeah he's super
thick I was asking Schmo bottom too but
I won't say it here but yeah he's super
thick
um so yeah he's asking Dana White to do
the uh obviously the Tyson Fury fight to
do both things he was said he would just
like a um pfl yeah just like he wants to
box him and he'll do it here's a
question for you fans out there leaving
the comments what sells more
pay-per-views
Tyson Fury Jon Jones boxing match
or Francis ingano Deontay Wilder boxed a
match
I know what I like more what Jon Jones
yeah yeah the thing about the marketing
behind it too yeah his face is way
thicker so thick yeah
it's strange right
that's how I was like
I thought he's gonna get more into his
body like lean up but that's what he
said he was gonna do I feel like maybe
he's just like he knows he's so good
he's like now you can just be a heavy
weight and do whatever I don't know
might be a little trouble if you fought
pavlovich Sergey Pavlich might have
something to say about that natural
heavyweight
eats whatever he wants you know I think
you can get away with this with the
steepe there but outside that you get
dicey for him
what sells more pay-per-views
Deontay Wilder Francis MMA fight or Jon
Jones Tyson Fury boxing fight
I think without a doubt Jon Jones what
do you think Casey yeah Jones all the
way around right no matter because you
have Jones the biggest name in UFC
outside Connor it'd be so cool to see
our goat and then you have Tyson Fury in
a ring like Ty's varies bigger than
Deontay Wilder so just number wise this
is a stupid question yeah it is right
either way both fights they're great I
love them
it's just funny Dana's like you know we
don't do those circus acts here and they
all do types days later yeah literally
later it's like that's not what we do
here I put on the best fights possible
we are a real sport
they're being said I'm down for Jon
Jones Tyson Fury MMA match and have some
male [__] ring card boys you know
you right hell yeah I'm in dude you
gotta give me three month notice though
I gotta fast dude I'd fast would you
really do it though honestly yeah I'll
do it see yeah it'd be super funny dates
I'll do it
yeah that'd be awesome
um this is just a interesting post by
Israel my weiner everybody's face would
be sick dude
so Auto science pushing for bonuses to
go up which obviously they should
um because he he mentions inflation is
one of the reasons but you know Fight
Night bonuses you know 50 is not [__]
for the FC and again we know they made
more money than they've ever made but
the bonuses stay the same yeah and they
did increase the bonus sometimes for
some reason they took it down yeah I
don't know why they was a hundred
there's 75 that's down to 50 50 across
the board now now they might do some
discretionary bonuses whatever I'm not
talking about that but when they say you
know when it's reported that we've made
more money than ever it's like okay well
then shouldn't everybody eat then
shouldn't everybody's purses go up yeah
including the bonuses
oh and also he made a point that since
they did that merger with WWE they have
like you know there's more assets more
money so way more why not more sponsors
yeah across the board that's why they
made so much money
yeah I think 100 000 sounds like perfect
should be more but I think it sounds
perfect 100 I said like hey inflation
has been going up the bonus has got to
go up that's how I feel well I've told
them this I've said this publicly it's
not crazy that's not crazy they're not
gonna do it but it's not crazy
he's spot on there 100K sounds good
that's what you need though you need
guys like cam saying we got we gotta you
guys gotta pay us more yes big no not My
overall purse because I'm sure is he's
taken care of but bonuses across the
board that's a small win for all
everybody
50 is nothing for the UFC 50k of course
not Dana gave the [__] you know the
milk boys no boys whatever it was 200
Grands for his birthday or some [__] I
know
um all right so
this kind of sucks I don't know if it's
true or not but they know what at a
press conference he's saying like no
absolutely Kamara Usman versus Hamza
shmayev is not happening
well that says [__] well that's a
bummer yeah
when is Hamza gonna fight now Shmoe on
the campaign goes I think it's these
issues
something's going on there can't be just
Visa because he can fight outside
of the United States they put on enough
fights there's nothing though there's no
smoke there's no there's no smoke we've
had on them where they smoke there's
fire but then this isn't happening
I don't get it because Kamara actually
wants to fight him too which is and
Hamza said just give me a [__] fight
here
I don't know the conspiracy would say
did something happen
suspended for something that we don't
know about he has not been around yeah
you're right
then how big is homzat massive and
there's there's just not fighting him
hmm
what's going on here yep there might be
something
okay so here's the rumor so Conor
McGregor was at a Heat game right NBA
Finals game I think it is you know this
I don't know if there's a Finals game or
not but it was uh yeah it was the finals
dude and game five is tonight in Denver
and Denver's gonna close it out and win
the finals the first time ever you've
never been to the finals
I don't know anything about it you're
gonna win tonight dude so Conor McGregor
punched the mascot and apparently the
headlines are saying that the mascot had
to go to the ER but he was fine have you
seen the punch he whales the show that's
a good punch for sure I don't like his
outfit there but here's the problem yeah
it's very strange but here's the problem
who thought this was a good idea
I'm with Dana he's like why why would
the mascot who in the NBA fighter
there he goes I mean real punch and the
weird thing he follows up with ground
and pound yeah that you can tell the
guy's like God damn dude what are you
doing
yeah even Conor goes and then he sprays
his uh you know pain relieving spray the
market is spray
yeah
yeah well your whole thing's weird yeah
absolutely I don't blame Conor like
anyone hit the mascot sure you like it I
was in France or something give him that
over him uppercut you know yeah who at
the NBA was like yeah let's have you
punch the mascot mascot it's like what
like don't worry dude your hair's your
head's down here the beak's up here he's
gonna hit the beak Conor in front of the
face if this is real I don't know I
think he's real oh okay
I don't know
yeah me too
um I'll say what though I'm kind of
jonesing for the uh for the ultimate
fighter tomorrow night starting to like
it yeah starting like yeah counting down
the days to Tuesdays now
was I didn't see episode two so it was
way better than one okay better all
right Connor still didn't show up to the
Wayne's but whatever
maybe that's the thing then it has to be
in this contract where he's like I'll do
it but I'm doing all this [__] I
don't need to be there
um this was announced last week but uh
UFC is going to return to Paris return
to Paris on September 2nd but they
haven't announced the fighter you tell
me homside can't find pairs I know right
why not what's going on here I don't
know what's happening
yeah I'm gonna start Googling stuff
about later then good luck finding
something yeah UFC's kept it pretty
Under Wraps
I've literally accepted every fight
Kobe's like yeah he didn't want to fight
me like that's not I said I would what
the hell is going on here Paulo Costa
remember that what happened I know the
podcast is fighting some random [__]
Russian like horrible fight for him I
don't know what's going on here
that's the biggest thing right now then
huh what the hell's going on with
hamzaad
hmm interesting right so if you're your
best guess would it be something to do
with asada
I would need to need I need more
information but it's definitely one of
my options because you don't have to
announce until you're actually convicted
right now then the rules change so that
would be interesting it's very I'm just
saying like I have that high profile UFC
doesn't have a ton of stars there's been
so many rumors we know Hamza is willing
to fight anybody any given time we're
all vying for it
his merch just dropped we've seen merch
can I help him out not a big deal but so
there's all this stuff
all of it makes sense
and no fights in over a year
what's going on there dude
yeah and it get I mean it's interesting
right I like conspiracies
it could just be like it's a VISA it
could be super simple but then that's
right announce that that's why
conspiracies are fun they're better than
the truth that's why we roll with them
because they're fun they're better in
the truth you know
they would just say hey it's a visa
thing but they're not saying anything
that's see that's where I'm like what's
going on here because they say nothing
yeah like and Dana's very vague on it
yeah trying to you know fight notice
also it's and it's like the White House
at the White House there's those
softball questions they don't they have
one guy from Fox but use this question
that girl shuts it down whenever it's a
buy it it's just softball questions well
Dana they pick and choose who's at those
press conferences
so there has to be a memo out there I
don't ask about Hamza when's the last
time somebody asked about Honda yeah
and I remember Luke Thomas even
mentioned before like this is your
livelihood is a media member you know if
you say something or you ask a crazy
question yeah you're out there goes your
money same with the White House yeah so
I get it
yeah weird right so I'm now I'm really
thinking that right
if you go to have the rabbit hole you're
like oh you saw it but who knows these
are all I'm not saying that he tested
hot I'm I'm all I'm saying is I want to
see the man something's up yeah because
and UFC needs Stars
yeah we're in the ecosystem when the UFC
has a star it's better numbers for us
when there's no stars our numbers are
down the UFC's down you know yeah it
makes no sense across the board for
anybody
let's see what happens hopefully maybe
chill knows I'm gonna text him and Luke
after this yeah
alrighty
um
let's see here oh this is just a quick
one boy what
what happened to your opinion man talk
about shooting yourself in the foot like
just being unlikable I love July opinion
oh I think she's great
she was like she I don't know why why
anybody's doing this you know she's not
she's not a big draw you know it's a
snooze fast when she retires she's like
I scared you into retirement like
she's talking a lot of smack yeah it's
so straight and she talks smack remember
one of the reasons you love Pena too is
going into that first amended newness
like she's like I'm gonna beat her
everyone's like you're out of your
[__] mind she beat her she beat her
yeah so there's some validation there
but it was just
you know her being like Oh I scared you
in retirement it's like did you not do
you do you beat up somebody forget the
rematch there's some 10-8 rounds there
girl that fight was not competitive
and she's like don't compare yourself to
answer and sell but you're just like oh
my God this is not the way to go yeah a
lot of fans were a little humble there I
but also I could see talking [__] to
Amanda Nunes if you were like a big star
you know what I'm saying like if you
were this massive draw you're like she's
boring nobody's paying attention but
it's like
you're a bigger star no right you know
it's just weird it makes sense
so she'll have her opportunity now a man
is gone now she'll have her let's see
what you do with your paper yeah star
you know we shall see so in this
particular video uh it's just a a media
member I think it might have been from m
a junkie so uh
oh Juliana was like saying like look I
have like you know knee scars from like
surgeries like zoom in yeah I can see it
okay so I'll just play
not too good yeah or no hold on let me
the Julian opinion have you ever broken
a rib spicy yeah you have and how was it
for you I got
him not too good yeah Ernesto I've
actually been ran over by a car too I I
got ran over walking on the sidewalk
yeah so just so you guys know I've
dislocated both my arms I've dislocated
or torn both my knees if you guys can
zoom in and see these scars I've broken
pinkies I've broken fingers I've got my
head split open this game is full of
injuries we are in the fighting game
creepy dude yeah but she this is her
kind of you know uh addressing the
rumors that she faked an injury to not
get into the newness fight she's a
fighter Spiderman yeah she's definitely
she went on her Shield even she got her
ass whooped she she put up a better
fight than aldana
yeah it's so stupid when people think
that broken rib is no joke I broke my
rib it takes a forever to heal because
the blood flow is not a lot there's not
a lot of like veins and you know all
that [__] there so circulation it takes
forever to heal it's hard to breathe
like that's a horrible injury
um
yeah I think I bruised my ribs and it
was incredibly painful
uh so this is Jon Jones at the Anthony
Pettis event and someone wore a shirt of
his uh his mug shot mugshot yeah and he
took a picture with
[Music]
he's putting that thumbs down yeah
trolls though that's an interesting move
with Jon Jones I would never yeah he's
one of the few guys that wouldn't do
that yeah yeah but I mean he took it in
good you know kids are doing things for
clicks though man
yeah
um there's really not much else uh let's
see okay this one case you can uh see if
we can play this video or not but so
someone's Instagram and this is a
Michael Jackson MMA thing okay I already
don't like this one
yeah
this is if Michael Jackson was an MMA
fighter foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah he's [__] really talented he's
so talented
[Music]
oh yeah I mean he has it done I mean
it's so funny
yeah I don't know his Instagram but
piranha
I don't know great okay fantastic cool
that's a good one to end on that's all
we have other than the fights this
weekend uh you a fight night is it
Saturday or Friday surprise Saturday
Saturday 7 p.m at the Apex which at Apex
kind of boring whatever uh yeah uh
Marvin vittori Jared Canon air it's a
important fight middleweight division
I'll roll my boy Victoria on that
sarukian's fighting Joaquin Silva
Petrosian uh Duncan
okay card
not great card that that one the main
event's important for the middleweight
Division and then uh
uh sarukian and Silva is important for
that lightweight division so
not bad Bellator is way better yeah just
be honest and I think this is a Friday
being completely transparent is belter
Bellator card is fire yeah nemcov Joel
Romero for the light heavyweight belt
you got uh Sergio Pettis Sergio Pettis
Patricio Pitbull Corey Anderson Phil
Davis
I'm not mad at all just those three
fights you should let you know it's a
better card than UFC it's a good card
dude Matthew Perry
Oh Yeah from friends fighting
yeah Showtime sick good for them good
for Bellator both busy weekend I'll take
it Friday Night Fights and Saturday take
my money all right kids thanks for
watching thanks for tuning in we'll be
doing such around La taking a little
break from touring this summer uh next
date on the books is July 28th shop and
friends then uh I have more a bunch more
dates but next one Spokane uh September
21st to September 23rd then I'm at skank
Fest September 29th through October 1st
Niagara Falls New York November 4th
through the fifth one show on the fourth
one show on the fifth that's a Casino
theater out there so Niagara let's do
this thing I have a bunch more dates
coming up though and those will be up
there and announce uh the new thick boy
merch the authentic thick boy jerseys uh
the Pinstripe one you got this gray one
we got hoodies they're not out yet they
should be coming out soon we'll keep you
guys posted but that's available soon
very soon hats hoodies
um new authentic jersey it's gonna be
lit all right kids all right man uh go
watch the new cow basketball fight
campaign available right now on thick
boy YouTube we have a very special
one-on-one coming up this week with a
great guest so looking forward to that
that comes out I think on Thursday and
that's it guys be safe be nice to each
other see you next time like subscribe
love you guys I'm out